DESTRUCTION AND VERY LITTLE IN
THE WAY.
AS I MENTIONED, AN AMERICAN,
JAMES HILL, THIS ASSAULT FRED IS
REPORTING ON.
CAMILA BURNOFF HAS MORE.
>> Reporter: BOMBING HAS
INTENSIFIED.
NO WAY OUT.
THAT WAS THE LAST QUOTE FROM
AMERICAN JAMES HILL BEFORE
CONFIRMATION OF HIS DEATH.
HIS FACEBOOK DETAILING A
CHILLING ACCOUNT OF HIS LAST
DAYS IN UKRAINE.
INTENSE BOMBING.
STILL ALIVE.
LIMITED FOOD.
ROOM VERY COLD.
ACCORDING TO HIS FAMILY, HILL
WAS WAITING IN A BREAD LINE WITH
SEVERAL OTHER PEOPLE WHEN THEY
WERE GUNNED DOWN BY RUSSIAN
MILITARY SNIPERS.
HIS BODY WAS FOUND IN THE STREET
BY THE LOCAL POLICE.
HE WASN'T SURE IF -- HE WROTE ON
MONDAY, VERY COLD INSIDE.
FOOD PORTIONS ARE REDUCED.
BOMBING AND EXPLOSIONS MOST OF
THE NIGHT.
HARD TO SLEEP.
PEOPLE GETTING DEPRESSED.
IN HIS POST HE DESCRIBES FEELING
HELPLESS, HUNGRY AND COLD.
WHILE NARRATING A WAR.
INTENSE BOMBING LAST NIGHT FOR
TWO HOURS.
IT WAS CLOSE TO THE HOSPITAL.
MACHINE GUNFIRE COULD BE HEARD.
IT STOPPED JUST AFTER MIDNIGHT.
HILL EVEN ENCOURAGING POLITICAL
ACTION POSTING THIS ON MARCH
7th.
FOR MY AMERICAN FRIENDS AND
RELATIVES, PLEASE PRESSURE YOUR
LOCAL REPRESENTATIVES TO
EXPEDITE AMERICAN VISAS FOR
UKRAINIANS, ESPECIALLY FOR
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN AND
SKILLED WORKERS.
ERIN, WHILE HE WANTED TO HELP
OTHERS, WANTED TO GET OUT, IT
WAS TOO LATE.
HIS FRIENDS ARE NOW DESCRIBING
JIMMY AS SOMEONE WHO WAS
WONDERFUL, WHO REALLY LIKED THE
OUTDOORS, LIKED FLY FISHING.
HE KEPT IN TOUCH WITH SOME OF
THESE FRIENDS VIA FACEBOOK.
SOME WERE SAYING THEY WERE ABLE
TO ESSENTIALLY SAY GOOD-BYE.
NOW THAT FACEBOOK IS FILLED WITH
CONDOLENCES, PEOPLE HONORING,
REMEMBERING A FATHER, A BROTHER,
JUST A BRAVE MAN.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
"OUT FRONT" NOW IS JAMES'S
SISTER KATYA HILL.
THANK YOU.
I'M SO SORRY.
LET ME START BY SAYING HOW SORRY
I AM FOR YOUR LOSS.
IT'S HORRIBLE AND UNEXPECTED AND
UNWARRANTED AS IT IS.
IN THOSE LAST FACEBOOK POSTS
FROM YOUR BROTHER HE SAID IT WAS
COLD AND FOOD WAS LIMITED AND
OBVIOUSLY HE HAD GONE OUT, IT
APPEARS, TO TRY TO GET FOOD TO
BE IN THAT LINE.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED TO YOUR BROTHER?
>> WELL, WE DON'T HAVE
CONFIRMATION FROM THE EMBASSIES
SPECIFIC TO HIS DEATH.
I DO KNOW THINGS WERE
DETERIORATING IN THE CITY.
HE WAS BRINGING BACK WHAT HE
COULD FIND.
HE WAS SHARING WITH ME ON MESS
SEN GER WAS HOW PATIENT THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE WERE WAITING IN
LINE OF MAYBE 100 PEOPLE AND
JUST TAKING WHAT THEY NEED AND
LEAVING FOODS AND OTHER SMIES IN
THE STORE FOR THE REST IN THE
LINE.
AT ONE POINT A MISSILE WENT BY
HIM AND LANDED AT A DISTANCE
THAT DID NOT HURT THE PEOPLE IN
LINE.
MY BROTHER WAS THE HELPER
PEOPLE FIND IN CRISIS.
HE FOUND SOME COOKIES AND HE
BROUGHT COOKIES BACK TO THE
NURSES THAT WERE HELPING AND
COULDN'T GET OUT TO THE STORE.
HE HAD A STASH OF CHOCOLATE THAT
HE WAS KEEPING SO HE COULD HAND
OUT CHOCOLATE WHEN SOMEONE
NEEDED ENCOURAGEMENT.
>> YOU KNOW HIS PARTNER.
SHE WAS IN INTENSIVE CARE.
HE STAYED IN UKRAINE BECAUSE HE
WANTED TO TAKE CARE OF HER.
MOVING FOR HER WAS NOT POSSIBLE.
WAS IT A HARD DECISION FOR HIM?
>> WELL, IN A SENSE, NO, BECAUSE
HE WAS NOT GOING TO LEAVE IRIS
BY IN HER CONDITION AND JIM WAS
IN UKRAINE THIS TIME BECAUSE HE
HAD GOTTEN MEDICINE FROM THE
UNITED STATES AND FOUND A DOCTOR
IN CHINA THAT WOULD TREAT HER SO
HE ARRANGED AN AMBULANCE TO
TRANSPORT IRA AND HER MOTHER
ALONG WITH HIM TO THE HOSPITAL
SO SHE COULD GET THE TREATMENT
THE MONDAY BEFORE THE BOMBING
STARTED.
WHEN SHE WAS ADMITTED TO THE
HOSPITAL THE DOCTOR THOUGHT SHE
HAD A MILD CASE OF PNEUMONIA.
LET'S TREAT THE PNEUMONIA FIRST
AND LET'S START THE MS
TREATMENTS AND OF COURSE IN TWO
DAYS THE INVASION STARTED BUT HE
WAS NOT GOING TO LEAVE.
>> HE WANTED TO TAKE CARE OF
HER.
HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO CONNECT
WITH HER?
>> NO.
>> NO, NOT AT ALL.
>> I DON'T SPEAK UKRAINIAN.
IRA'S MOTHER HAD TWO PHONE
NUMBERS SO WE HAD A GROUP THAT
HELPED WITH IRIS' CARE AND
RESPITE FOR HER MOTHER.
WE'RE TRYING TO REACH HER, BUT
THE LAST TIME THAT I SPOKE WITH
MY BROTHER THE ELECTRICITY WAS
OUT, THERE WAS NO HEAT.
IRA WAS TRANSPORTED TO THE --
WELL, TAKEN TO THE ICU A FEW
DAYS AGO BECAUSE IT HAD BEEN SO
COLD IN THE HOSPITAL FOR SO MANY
DAYS.
BUT THE PHONES, MY BROTHER SAID
HE WAS RESERVING BATTERY ON HIS
PHONE BECAUSE YOU COULDN'T
CHARGE THEM.
I CAN ONLY ASSUME THAT IRA'S
MOTHER'S PHONE IS UNABLE TO BE
CHARGED AT THIS POINT.
>> YOU TELL THESE STORIES ABOUT
YOUR BROTHER AND THAT HE WOULD
JUST TAKE ENOUGH FOOD THAT WAS
NEEDED AND TAKE SOME TO SHARE
WITH THE NURSES AND HELP WITH
OTHERS.
WE SEE THAT ON FACEBOOK PAGES
WHERE FRIENDS ARE POSTING YOU
WILL NEVER BE FORGOTTEN, A TRUE
HUMANITARIAN CAPTURING THAT PART
ONE SAYING HE WAS A WONDERFUL
MAN WITH A BIG HEART.
SO CLEARLY THIS IS WHO HE WAS.
KATYA, IT'S GOING TO BE SO HARD.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SENSE AS TO
WHERE HE IS?
ARE YOU GOING TO BE ABLE TO BURY
HIM?
ARE YOU GOING TO BE ABLE TO
HANDLE THE GOOD-BYE AT ALL OR
NO?
>> WELL, ACTUALLY, THAT'S ONE
THING THAT WE'RE STILL TRYING TO
REACH OUT TO SENATOR KLOBUCHAR
AND I'M IN PITTSBURGH SO SENATOR
KASEY'S OFFICE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE MY BROTHER'S
BODY IS SO THAT KIND OF CLOSURE
THE FAMILY WON'T HAVE RIGHT NOW.
SO ANY HELP THAT SOMEBODY CAN
LET US KNOW ON THAT WOULD BE
GREATLY APPRECIATED.
>> I HOPE SOMEONE HELPS.
>> PRAYER SERVICES, MY SON IS AN
ORTHODOX PRIEST, SO HE WILL DO
WHAT'S CALLED A PONAHITA OR A
PRAYER SERVICE FOR MY BROTHER AT
HIS PARISH IN NEW JERSEY AND MY
PARISH HERE WILL DO A PRAYER
SERVICE, BUT FINALIZING, THAT
WILL PROBABLY BE OUR HARDEST --
HOW CAN I SAY?
THE HARDEST THING THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO GO THROUGH IS
NOT HAVING CLOSURE.
>> I AM TRULY SO VERY SORRY FOR
YOUR LOSS OF YOUR BELOVED
BROTHER.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I HOPE THAT --
>> HE WAS MY ONLY BROTHER AND I
REMEMBER GROWING UP AND HE
PESTERED ME A LOT AND MY MOTHER
WOULD SAY, NOW, I DIDN'T SEE HIM
DO IT SO IT DOESN'T COUNT BUT I
WOULD GO BACK FOR THOSE MOMENTS
AN